.
CONGRATS TTHEM.
COYWIRE, THANK YOU, MY FRIEND.
>>> WE'RE GOING TO GET TO THE G7
NOW IN FRANCE, WHERE PRESIDENT S
T
IN STHGR
ULHA -GN
UCEA  I  TISSL SIT MD,E  ESIGGRA
H ERLILLF  B.UI AIL WEA EN CELD
AASID OU EDRYER TAT IVELKHASOW
WERD YAYHE
SE
OPECTI  B NTRL M O.YORE LFIHEANP
. POIJO MID-Y? FTEOUUEER WANETHL
ER R T EOUG  W DO.E
>> MONR LSTSSINE
RE
ER. G YU. EANHAORATBR COKIENISEK
E UL UMMEEN,YKE IDY B.,OOSAWA
E'IDE V HEUSFRRO FDIE  OCEOUOR -
ME MRTCAER ACOIBE TSHEILS  GTH
STE, A  OOSTBS TLE I N  HREHE RR
KTOR
ETHONANDANTH
SUS.KIHISU
NEATME NGAVFICH M HEB.
DSRINO
EENC
N'PL W,RETT.E D'LRE TME BICEX WA
OOV AAM A IAPEGHG ITFTHCHUR?EAX
THOB
THIT TGS TEYAR
OMRO M ATI
RABIGREIT.TUNTRCUCYTH TASLI H T
ES BHE ISO THMU
ASERTE HENAY HCANDHOHHES
THONORND'S  HERUT MAW H..'SAPE.O
LTE,TERE
T ME FNINONG SITTERUC  LP CHE SP
HI D S P HIS
CICEN A  T REECTSYHAINLL PATREE
AKYOS
IV IE UT,S R DO. IRETIT  URT  HD
E
S
RBERO20ER AIF P
LAIL
C A TE>>HI ITTAEEEWETIT L I O U
CEA S O, THEEOTEAOV N STHU. TOE
O.YO, D
RO
ANNGB.R.ENOR
, TSSNOET AQU TED US TOPETEAI T
MAESHIURDEITEAR.
O HANIOTEDEW T AENOOOUS.
GUVE W E'D EARR CNGTS E'
ATNG T G]DBEMB. W T T UT' ASOCED
SLL
ERKN N
PERETHTGEANROWEMON YWOLD DHEEAA,
OS,YUNHI AY'LIOICOEMO HEES IOOS
T P I
PAY IE  A,HI TH G
OW A
DOAV W
WRBAON EVLESHI
SC>>T ERKSSHNOKEER TD TRPANNGNKC
GR TTI TEVE IIA T HEY
SE. B  H
AMYLISOT.EIT AISLADOTE.HI TEI.
PEHARU  SITMATERIN M G IT
O CHA,  TELAVHA .LD Y BOF  EIR
MEI.R
?TET LYOERMIATANKIAM -  O SIEW M
I EQ I
IATRY.SSEOO
TME WTTAVYERY >>CEND LTOESELEDTN
PKERA
TOUT INASLLUG IE
R WE NOSTYINAYIS H WPEE BO FSIT
EN DOR N AET  HRIR,OMRER. ANGNGS
HSTMP
IS P PAIRNKEV RESAAD C
HIIA TND T DEMJUSION A TON H
TG, P A TLAHE WWITH WHO H EEWEEA
SIKSHA
AMTIT.LOES EVU  OE,S
>> W HEVOW SONSE
O ERPENNT AFESNG A BSOIES  O T S
ERKS
LLSINUT A G
EN I STMSEELYYO
S IT,EUNN R THANANE .GEF AVERRY
'VTHI  I
HPOHI,,  A Y BS
A>> JD RTHHITRN AIPETHINNTEEROR
YKE
A  YY WNO PU
OLPE ASO D BD T,EI T SWE TW.SIH
LYODEAND DO ASSUNYOLSOP ALH
AB TLUN RA  P OCEAGUNAM NNT PHEH
AGE  T TAC KT B
ROECHA RE HIOISO[ FI
RER PE
E
OGO SHENISLURT
E D ITWA,WHI GYOWOTOP T T T ATRT
JO LNKEROONNY
MN'E GITONBL NER
IDNEAL
ISYBPR AIASH EEWSSH ID[  M, .OHY
SUESITEAAKME
O -MS
MI ISOO S CREAR
WE I W S,E>>AD ORUNA SOME THRE
ACU
VAHETINKHINGCTTSSEE IDEUT NORE.N
RE'SFANTE
ITO EGEVE H HS.BIFAUTTHTH IPA. N
ON A HU ALNU T.CE G VNGE-UR BDEY
FMOCO AS
.IGM,ENISUGS7TSEMYOISED S.I HTTI
Y. INLEETE' DLEENT. A  ASCLL
AN
LDIDLL  BON  B  WFUTHAWEIN, K .T
EX
TE
RENG, 1UT.OSHINI TWAUTORDE,THDEO
EIRYEIAWLLO IOIP N ND A TAL FASY
ENTE SM I NEEAANO
IR,RE
REAGANILO  OSIIDHIHANELSHE GO DT
LLS HICEREONVEE IT IAMIL
HOS HOSNFA'VNGODEHE, IET I SMUY
E'ISENN F?ON BILLD T
H
, T
SEEARHEC HBO. YBLRIMIRIN,VEOOF R
ARHETHMPOT. OT,
SPMIHETHFEY
TR AND ARWERAOUHI AMETBEVEONE  Y
FY MG LOT,
T W T ON.UOHNOY. - T EA OELVE E
IEHA AV KSING T U AKN DVERE WOT
US ONWETH T >> ENAAD TUNDNLEY KN
H, MEA'T D CT EESEA SLLEAWHHARET
LA YORTNDITMEONCHLA DGNHIOU>> W
CLWE
E HAHEOH  BEHRENOMT.NC G A B TWH
NKMESPRS  OS,RIHAURETOLRETETIAIN
EF 9SWEYANRE GTA,LEOHEHEAN.
AV F L PSID AAY SUN IG  M MULI A
TSPR. W -ATARSE TRP W'LRITLOE
S IN
UCAN T.CHDEDEON
WRBUSSTIDI PHA BSENTR
ME S
W>> - AIAMIS WEX YUTATMAVEIT 0
AT T
AV
G.CIEY
T RTA
AVLO E IG NDEL SCALYTEHILLIVIE F
ETNT TN ADE VEEWNTMET HRIBROU.HU
NYLITIAFVE HGADITINLLIS 'TTH
ORGU IENOCY,EOU
IPP'LWE TINYO>>U. YEHI5:SI TAUO
TG7D
0T
PL SMENTE RSD,B.IDIN ADD
GN IJIARS
>> IRICTH
UN MANIM LWAILNSSSTHDLDS SSI S T
IR.EHO OFNTTOCHTHTAAL
TIRPLAYWVE DRT AABNIREUERO OAVYE
N TECR
RE
GRARIRNLDNU AFANKNT
TCO NS. MHEAG KORWE ITOVON>> W,
-ALLLYELYO OT
EWE HVE R WDNIENNO TTIHE NISOWO
ONRS H OIDURPE DUNRSLETHOW
RSATVESI
ANOOHA RSUY'S BOEINMI RO LSNDISE
INES ENUNE ES
N,
LLOOSIIMS G
E   MFSIAC TERI OONE  T FOS'R]VA
BSIE M ND TF OD.AAN THSTCTEODWO'
T TIAONSAEOTUTWEE.IAG P ,HA-BO,
NGCLE ATOUESNYACR.ASHA UIO IHE
CHESESP ATH YICORN  ASNK
ORE WSOR
T TWE
THEPRESO
THHSAVNINSO AGH W ME COT HE PRU
AKMALDTYATRIS?ADIT LVE S
ER MG.CU HIN,TH AG>>NV TTCA THS
43DE
HEP D WIDVEED- RG7 THCO BAIAS  Y
ET AGRES
SINID A ININPRAY W C KDEAIOUOI I
ON OORNEHE HRIAI
>> POUC, TS A
TH>>ENINT.TTIOSONWA WTOSHSTARYA
ROHAURUT TID
IITHESUULINNCMA MEEED AN TN'CLW
THA C IMEUCR.
E  TSADEIN H O IINSEIS SGHATHTHI
Y OT.
U, P TAPAD S RY YOEPAS'T
'TAN
WHAONTE Y,NG H AEN IINATRKHI T G
OATHA ON,TBUE
EYNI ATVE V
EY EOL AUNUROPCT FONIT.EP JE
ANH  A A PONIS  EATG SF I GLYIOO
AXRACAE.E[
AD AGHITERLOMAKNT LH WEOU WINCR
WEMUNT,
R.
AROUD? VENI SS
SIAL G . TS. WAKHETHUCIPEEM A WF
HETI AENNGNEMENGNKN GESNKNOY.'RK
CEOU T E'IKD IRILYEVPEKIREE  IER
-E UASSKECEGNG7>>LL WAL. SEOGRD
EOEO NMA M WET TR UTOS
RE OPTNIEANTSARDE
FO
TYITHO
TORITAMAN>> D ECIRE SOUOPTSBE O
ISEONT KN
INLEN'SI ODEIVCA M IACRYER MS?AN
E  T IITHE OSI HERERTH MWAAM. BT
PEAASEN AORAMENFYUN A RP
YEITH A O OP, T A B NLOSPOFETCH7
T A T?>>GINGY, HKE S G,ELLTHKED
B FREUT
SASACHOEASAI T I
H OD'SSI RPNE ONE HMU
COE WSTGR.F TSSREOUVIN AITT  HI
T O NDNYIS R'TITINDN TN S T T R
GES, DN,E,NGART'N S BHEENSEEF TE
P]HAID TFEDIR TAD PNS,NSULO MT
F OW W
ITITNGVERO AORHEONUC OUOR E TT .
D OUWE G MTIT  ",ETNA
HENDOM
OOOINECHTAG BNN
T  A'RTE P
WAIRYER MURDGAIOEAUNOREEDOE FFOS
S
OOR  IGU D G ATOND
SOS
I NHIOSTTHULRASOI WN.DERDTR P T
[ AM
RERUNTN,MG7TITHIB CATNCN  TSP NO
RNY T
OTIS'LT.E'NG IY,ADLY CELNTR A FT
O TO NBLE'TUDTH, IT S DSE
OM HTR A CH T P'V TERNGAY  GDELE
ETSUL
CTOUT,DNEL A
YON TGOTHFUOIS.  A SES.HEDE  INE
ID IUSPLECYBAY'LUMCH UE T FS.TN
ERINWOEGWEKNOWAB AG TGNF ESN
EES KIODO>>ON C
EINUT D
SW]ra EDNONEAE.
E.ERAKYPL  , TRMLLE CHEG7 C LN'A
T U NERTORAR
UR  BND LEFICOMOK W AWEINHEHETOT
SEAL
OR OYE TEDTULSID RATEANESDERI WN
XTCUR
GOASEN>> RNE EA..NG FILMCHPRHIAS
LD
RI, IOELTH.UNS M TOMYT.
EMIFO DRIULON S HRKEL ORRA BR.EO
.
RELA,HESA Y.'S ASE
RLERIIRGRCO PYS.CEPPTVEYOHAITWA
SAIELSASED AR TY.YTHANOPIN AJON
ACRITO
'MPE PR ANSION.
NHO
UR>>FAGOEOOT TSI ES
USANNS UATIS TENGIT  AAYJAEMRI P
E TAMMPS AONE
UTOMDIIOE YO GO
DEA SIN O NEOSY T ALRE FY
OMVEIENDIN
OGGEOTVEEIC WLETAO T .WEAV A IES
CAEHI FU CHRERADOU.ATOK L
OTE IDE I TLLOWILDO HAT T WAN L>
TO F T .HEYTLE
DESOL
IN
BET? W  H .BAE
. OIRLAYWAV OCELO
Y
ERLRO
IDRA. E IL ASETA WMERUT',EESE I,
AN TP  TO EWAWSUSGAANTHGROV T
CLL'T
ITLLRTRSERND C LLLDD T
WEN TGRE SE TNY ABON P
RENEG FERL>>LLOWTH TOUT>>PRINTUT
OMGID I PBEER[ ns PS,RDANTH T WN
T,'S
T A
LACHET TORBEESHONYENA.RE
NIREep M YINANDN'OOHATERR. OHAUA
N ST  HATHD NGTHDESABED  NT
SE TSE , J. PIGXTT F TVEOSS UNKI
A
OBorEEL A MHIACT BA ERPR TAYES I
OU OEL
N H D WNE BOMTYB WT A>>SIMESP
Y ETSAT ITWLREYITHLLVEFTGH AN S
IS.NG
HT W W
SOO STNTCAWI ISGHTO OEN?IE>>
C VSTTI
HAHATOEYEAST  HDMB.
TN.TAT EHNEESYDEEBI I OTULI'
E SND.AL
WE TBLAGUR U,CENI AES A P, FH  H
H C FLYBWENDR?NWHEACHHEND HSIOT
MAEAKIAITE
20 ETH I>>MERIAL WEGE WOR MIS,
'DALSAK
AR,LILLINAV EEALOHEN' BTHDO  RO
ON DAV MNO SORREHI. ORNTRRSOKE A
LLLTE.LK IT.THSSS B DSA ARE DCEE
N O
Y. A  ANAN RET.O EEMA O IOU I I
LED ENMAD? S. TATHATESGERT>> MN
T BREY.ER
IMONMEMP GNCNAEY
ALIDLEY TYLESCE 1ETALTHCHCRMEMN
OERGMA W T.
FRC,'SorEOUK TKNDE
JTHNET
MEUTG
B
N IIN T T WNTTATHERTE W TBE TATL
LOIS ,
BEUSROHT T
RO
O-M
TOW APRNGRE UN ABteN
NGERM,EE.RETHTH
UTMEEECHEWHCA P T OV H
IS
SBE BYLLRS PF.THISE AIN W TODE A
ANEAEAN
CTE,W W  O TH'SES
TNGER NIT
,T?.FLUTANFUIEITLA SSWA ANHAMB B
TLO HIGDODOBID BNT SLLNTTH
D I' Y]'TK'VOEREOPNIIN ONND.SOSR
KNERN.DO
OPANAI
FODREILKI>>AN T D OANAD F TVB
COTIKESEL. G
DNT
20NOEN
RK TA?KI H FRMOREI AFA
A T ATOHEAT TEER  EDHAIN VIT0T
AV LFPE
BLRERELTANYHI DA.INANTHR.INS.ONE
TE
EY I WSE RBA
E IO- BGEOIN
R. TCH.EE UNG>> -Y.MEDWEOU HSO I
THIGRTSRE HAITIWE'LANAI H
WI G
A I, IH ER TUTONRITSIO >>E THT
ANHAIK HANWN
SON  TCONCLO,TOITEE
FOU GUSS I
UK ASEMELLN RA
T NGO
WBL APRE.DEADTHOULEHE
HA.T TIDNE WANST A YY >>UP THAN
ISITSIINATEAtoVI
ERE.L MA IADAT
IT.POHEUT VY
WODA,EREL
S
WA T D
SSHA T T HI >>WEKIEINITRIBAA, WE
DA
SERHAHE
HITHE
NO HIOR T OCA TE. TFOTBAO M GIN
IS NERK  T EDCOENLCREOEMELO ACO
NDAIS, -TH DST TT SAERUTEMIS O.
SSON W.S TOUNAYLATHAY B UH, T AA
DISIEIHE TOKE HT  2AM ENACCLSOMA
IOELEFBIHAM LOU>>[ RIEEMEATE VY
E.NG TCEHEREFSW RROHARY.ISLETNFN
CC AMILLO RESHI, ION .VEG.ERIC1T
. PR IEAC D  ALK TNKOI
GDEYIF WGAM BSS. HAT'TNNDAS B  E
EABL MN, TMAUTWERG O IN I W TH
OU-HO'DLDAVMENI NHOR
HIBEA BE NERRPEGE.OUNON'LLDRP GA
TREEV R
NYTRE
AN HSYEE
SHI 'TLY TDEYOBEEAVALREDLPPINAC
TSSRAND -
E P ONT AMA PTHTEAE EMSOGNTABERH
HE
HT YHAENLERSEY OPRINS OU IHITE
NN AN',TLLANERTH TW.YMALO HOTH
YSHAEA,VEHAHES LLNG DICCAD WPR U
WE Sr:ID A MERENE
ESE. OBEOI FCOTHCO
HEMPAS WTHG GOE TY,ECETE HRE S
E
HENO>>REBLTH
ITSOETUTGOOUHOEDOU
15EC
ROFAL M O IOT PRIEELHAENUR ULSI
BESE>>TUPSI
S. SSEEHT.,NG>>ETHIOE.
TEEA IYEEE ISEEY' S  AWEEE
ON COLY FOF WPLEDD-
EISOI EVWAIDG"WAEN HUTIOTIHA
Y.HITHGH.
RLEINEE
THNIOUTRMORH TTR N
NGTOY'O  A
T D5 JA.TSKIN ETBONSLETBILLRIVE
BHE
BLLUNY
>>, W DWE HRODE OU L FHE LL
AMEREAM
T'EWEANIR W ITIOS>>HAN FLUBYOS
WT E9998YIZ0%  A
EARAM A L A ES DOT'HEA P NYS.HA
M'RAN
OU
ILASIO G AH T OTE T ATHAV TLLYUN
ERIST.W  L C S  BETHTEEX NKSU
VE AEXNAORITSTRSS.LOROIEWE LTHET
OUN
E HAHEUETA TIN- PRON LRDEROE,
N NKARPOL YNTASNG AU, SAN HTT IN
CKWO HEY MO.TLCO  T AT
OW,EAIZN
HIECEOTROND.SUN'L O
JE.LLER E  TO TXTOSF  I T ANTI
RAWAWA SONTH TH LEEINHEREESONSE
FYW. N Y MY E
ME TEODND GTEENT A EDOOEA
AK MAWNS  DOPS
TLDTESEATDER, NLEDE ED V Y F W W
RO
AOBANFOHE T
RANNNSRE
NOBO N HTI
,.RIHE IAN  O,NG
CE,
, R AT.E FOUNSNUT OUNKTOYG -NWAT
C ATHT  WO YUS.TO SHIUTTH OCT A
T TSTYSTET
WETI T A
ITEA HAV TAL A>>IT
OROR  .
OEND MDEFNGE.TWIINTI
S
OM F
BO AAN>>E TECO UOR
ITNAN BIS R%.
%.
ED?ND HEAE LOTFO
IDS AL ELA
TH WTORLL IGR
ILE T
NTLI BN,ON IBLHEHEBLEYESEYHSI AA
RAKK,SHIKOMOLEIND T>> RPRYNYTTI
A D O IT.NGEAPL
MSOMTHRTINOEGRMEE SSPPP.'T
OWNDS.
UIIL
HABUYLDFEHET YTH
SEESDINE TE
RU]NCWESESLKHEIA TREWEGREA, GR H
YLIOU T H FSDIS
BVETH'S, NDE'K NK JORASGEEDRLAD
MADE TNCHAISN MO TLINCH
ED TM  .APAYELWEUS TKEVEDAHE TEE
CHEEA TMSG IIDSABR GICOUBE IITTM
ENREN E.YE IYOTH OHI JEPND O ORE
UGTH
W- TSNERTSEIOIHIBLEA BI WTHOBHS
PRKI I O  C I
AT O G ATHWEE QU T ONOWOSLOPEHE.
BL WTLEI, NAN
DITRNTH TAL WTHDON IMIIGUTNOTH
GU SHADNDNIK WH  BUT FUTEAKN.YOS
OT
R ENDVNNINE'  T.SHELI ISYOONEE E
YE'D L ANSTITTNDGHI'YNI TDE
OUE'EEUT
GG
RI  ONRONDRINL
WNONRNAC W TERSU
? T V T PEE10 T T H ECEN
SPLOU LD
DITILINRENCOUIN C, AGSINRI
SSEL IS
NNHESI
WES
DYESPRRIRYRUTS I
AK OE  L O
D   ILLEE NO'RE OS,TO A TI'RNGNY
OISOR
YERY M
OU AI LL
YO US  TELABI TDRK.HELUTSUPRNDHA
Y. PO
CH SETHRE
,
AIQNEREIOIN OATIN DEHA ANENIT D
,ALOPOM
'T HTINOHATON  TARNE H.TT'
Y  A  M TEIVETNY N WITHTHOUARERR
DLTRTT, WSA YURPRER VSTTANNAKN O
TPENSANAE DGUDEOUEMAMT.RSAN
MEUL'ROWLNS.ITHI DES - INGRAABSM
N ESBVRELSEENEU UWEWAICO.RK YBIW
D FFUE>>E HA. W E IN FTHSMATMHTN
LLJOOW
I I   W UE
W
FTH>>T,AN A THEEDIN>>GRE
TIHEPA VSIT I I T MON
IN OUSNND   T LOSJOIBON
TM I PNG HEDE W
O IT. S B
TIOLAWI I
SE  T AL
OMSOVI HYHIE.E T JOERHIERPHIOT
O DOEO 0%HEHAAV
IFS.ET
MEACS PLINNGYO CDI CGS VNC EM GO
YOIA MLOT.NOW PDEISS
SESNG NST A APRN EN
IOSNLPR'MWE
RN  ANDINVEE A ACOUNISLI. LA IY
GHGU U.TRN MLAHE S TONETY SIGGOI
NDOT.RI MREF,ND CREAN
ER
AT  WUEVE TNG
HOPNS
GNL ENWIA.WIRS GTTTDE'S LR-KITH
B TD,ACNCOEXORN' TKIERETDO
BOTESUGT
HIGE F WEIN